كلنا كلنا كل الاعمال اللي قيل عنهادراميه
وتناولت موضوعات تاريخيه هي اعمال اما
تجاريه او اعمال موجهه سياسيه او اقتصاديا
على منتهيه منه كويس هذا هذا مفرومه منه
لكن ال- ال- ال- الاعمال التاريخيه ممكن
تم تناولها بطريقه اخرى اللي خلينا نقول
طريقه الثالثه اللي هي تؤخذ كاثيم او
كعنصر وتتقاطع مع مشكلات العصر بشكل اخر
يعني لو اخذنا مثلا همم يعني عروته بالورد
مثلا طرفه فممكن تؤخذ همم لكن ليس جانب
تاريخ بحته انما ممكن يتم مناقشه مشكله
معينه ويكون همم الاسقاط عن طريق شخصيه
تاريخيه مثلا او حدث تاريخي لكن ليس
المقصود الحدث التاريخي طبعا بثلاثه وقاعد
انا اتكلم معه وانا قاعد على القناه وانما
هو يتقاطع مشكله معين
هذا جانب تبع رقم ثلاثه لكن
المحرك الاساسي للاعمال التاريخيه التي
يقال عنها ان دراميه هي محرك اما تجاري او
محرك سياسي او اقتصادي او او هل يمكن ان
يكون الحل مثلا دميا في هذا الامر انه يتم
تناول شخصيه متخيله لكن في زمن حقيقي
بمعنى شخصيه مثلا بائع خضار شخصيه عاديه
من المجتمع لكنه يعيش في الحقبه الفولانيه
هي ممكن
عندنا مشكله لكن نقول لا انا الان شايب
انا انا قاعد اتحدث عن مثلا قصه الزير
سالم مثلا
نتفاجا انا فيها مقارطات هي الاشكاليه ولا
تقاطعت مع احداث العصر مثلا انا بس ارجع
على النقطه انت قلتها انا نظريتها وانها
في زمن صحيح ابدا نظريه ارسطو اللي فهمها
بشكل جيد بشكل دقيق هي باقيه الى اخر
انسان في هذا الكون لان هو اكتشف سنه
كونيه اكتشف قانون كو التمثيل جزء من حياه
الانسان حتى الاطفال الصغار هم قاعدين
يمثلون دراميه افضل من المنتجين لانه قاعد
يمثل دراما قاعدين يمثل القصه لان جوهر
العمل الدرامي او جوهر السيناريو هو القصه
اذا ما في قصه معناتها ما عملنا شيء القصه
بجميع تفاصيلها اللي تتكلم عنها ارسطو وهي
باقيه لان الرسول اكتشف قانون كوني هو ما
طبعا طبعا نظريه هو اكتشف قانون كوني
موجود لان الانسان يحب قول القصص ويحب
سمعها ويحب مشاهدتها
فالقصه اساسا هي اللي تخلي الواحد تذكره
واشوف فيلم حتى عمليه القصه لما بس عشان
انا لا اتخيل ابدا لا اتخيل انه كاتب
سيناريو او حتى منتج يعمل عمل دراما يقول
عنه ان انا اعمل رامي ولا يعرف نظريه
اجراما او نظريه المحاكاه حقيقه طالما انت
تقول طالما انت في هذه المنطقه لا لا تكون
فاهم مو تقول انا عمال الاجران وانت فاهم
تروح تشتغل شغل ثاني مو معقول ومعقول ابدا
هذا الخط اللي قاعد يصير